okay [ __ ] and we are back we're back
we are doing what we're doing okay
really we're going to go sista dragon
this is the drag of sites at night this
is the jackson fight notice of that
chicken no you don't want to go up there
a dragon it's attacking its lure with it
I don't know what it's doing up there
but I'm not waiting around to find out
yeah
take on this bench
that cheese geez Louise here and there
it is try get up there just try to get
up there long ass past and second
shuttle usted
heliconia he grew up on the south
how to kill me
Oh
[Music]
you
talking truck
put a good stretch
those are a second dragon here
songs
god it's true isn't it you really are
dragon I would say I am after I killed
the dragon I owe you some answers don't
I go ahead whatever you want to know
nothing held back sorry [ __ ] I'm one of
the last a very long time ago the blades
were dragons for the last 200 years
since the left now that dragons are
coming back our purpose is clear again
the first thing we need is the Fowler
our best lead if they aren't involved
they'll know who is the faction that
rules the Auld Mary Dominion there's no
worse enemy to humankind in camarillo
the Empire barely survived the land war
the foul more don't intend to lose the
next 10 the first thing we need to do is
figure out who's behind the dragon up
it's out in your drive nests bleed if
they aren't involved don't know who
you'll be in front of my try again
the first thing we need to do is figure
the Fowler our best lead there before
the great our grand map so we bought a
minute shadows nothing saw the Empire
had and now the dragons who else gains
from that but the style more if we could
get into the Thalmor problem is that
place is locked up tighter than a misers
I'm not need me back and River keep an
eye on the sky this is only go thank ya